The first Haitians told us, friend,
I don't eat tortillas, I don't eat Colom,
from there they communicated to each other
that food was already being sold and that this
is how they began to arrive,
they tell us that it is a little piece of
Haiti, friends
[Music]
my name is blues and castle and
we cook food and I tend to the
sweet snack bar
most haitians came to ask for
death to the usa but it was only then that
they found bad news that
they were not allowed to pass many
decided to stay here in tijuana
us  We were the first to make the
food and
many people said, friends, I don't have any money, I do
n't bring it, we also gave the food
to the first ones, they suffered a lot, they
did arrive a lot without money without clothes
because they still stole everything from us and for not
having even blankets and well  we gave them
blankets here right
now we make several or they make a
fist of white rice with their little
pig's hand in leggings
the majority here in the food is spicy
because they do eat  spicy but not how
we eat it
is a reason that is very different from
ours there is something that unites you that is from
your land and that knows that you are going to eat
something from your country
many times they tell us egalitarian
like that like that  tell us well if you don't
get feelings
if the last ones who left came and
thanked us then you didn't
force me to be comfortable that
you leave happy with that I'm well
paid